[Music]
hello and welcome to atp report i'm
barry nussbaum i'd like to remind all of
you in atp land remember you can sign up
for our email list directly simply by
going to find barry.com findberry.com
it'll take you to the atp landing page
you can sign up for all of our content
like today's stuff and everything else
from our special guest today absolutely
for free and you'll get it in your email
on a regular basis which is now the time
to bring in our favorite guest on atp
report robert spencer you know him as
the author of over two dozen
best-selling books on
islam in jihad around the world he's the
founder and editor of jihad watch he is
the expert on what's going on with
insurgencies around the world welcome
robert spencer always good to talk to
you barry thank you thanks for coming on
with us today so president biden's
nominee for the supreme court has a
history of representing
terror suspects when she was a federal
public defender in washington she well
she went well beyond the bare bones
defense to attack the united states
government and some of its
counterterrorism policies
she claimed that we the united states
was violating the geneva convention in
regards to her
client's rights at gitmo she represented
some detainees who challenged even being
imprisoned and i wonder if those views
have stayed with her now
by way of background i have a good
friend who was a marine major at gitmo
she was in charge of one of the wings
security she said her prisoners lived in
better conditions and ate better food
than her marines
in your opinion robert can judge jackson
be impartial in regards to these terror
undesirables when she sits on the
supreme court if that should happen
well in the first place barry she's
never retracted or expressed any regret
for anything that she did in those days
and so we have every reason to believe
that she still thinks that the american
government is committing atrocities in
guantanamo and that these people are
being deprived of their human rights and
so on it's a standard leftist myth but
it is a myth
the
guantanamo supposed concentration camp
is the only place where the prisoners
actually gain weight
while they're there and uh there's no
mistreatment of them uh not not even
remotely so
it's just as
an unfortunate indication
that
the miss jackson is a standard leftist
with anti-american views just the sort
of person we don't need on the supreme
court but the left is increasingly
anti-american
biden is beholden to the far left and
his party and so we're getting an
anti-american supreme court justice
sure seems to be my friend the major
said she wished her troops got food as
good as her prisoners got
they
8k rations
and the prisoners had a chef for each
wing on a daily basis for three meals a
day she wanted that food and she wasn't
allowed to give it to our own troops
i'm not surprised no kidding so israel
has just experienced their third
multiple murder terror attack in a week
and these are attacks inside of israel
palestinian terror groups are praising
the daily shooting attacks including the
one at banay barak that left five
israelis dead
um
this is just outside of tel aviv and
palestinians are celebrating like crazy
all over palestinian media hamas is
telling
their followers this is the harbinger of
our people's operation to come deep
inside the zionist entity meaning inside
israel islamic jihad the same thing
showing palestinian men jumping up and
down
shouting slogans to destroy israel
and the world is quiet robert what could
be done to get the truth out about these
multiple murders and why they're being
committed
well the media just doesn't want this
kind of thing to be reported
because we have to understand and i
think altogether too many people still
don't understand that the media is not a
news source at this point it's a
propaganda the arm for the far left and
they have a narrative and just as we
discussed in other contexts before
they have a narrative about israel that
israel is an oppressive apartheid state
and the palestinians are the poor
oppressed victims and so
when palestinians act against israeli
civilians and murder israeli civilians
it doesn't fit the narrative it doesn't
get reported
uh what the
jihadis apparently want to do is
actually shore up
that narrative
uh israel has been increasing the number
of palestinians
allowed to work in israel
this was never restricted before and
only got to be restricted in the first
place because of jihad terror attacks
like these
and then israel began relaxing a lot of
these restrictions now
probably they will be put back and that
will reinforce the media narrative we'll
hear a lot about that
and about the supposed oppression and
apartheid but all it is really is israel
trying to defend itself against this
relentless gi
well said
i i gotta ask you these two questions
because for the life of me i don't know
the answer maybe you do
uh judge jackson who we've discussed
before is uh going through hearings
probably on our way to a confirmation to
the supreme court and she's had two
impossible answers uh to give at least
from her perspective the the senators
that asked the questions expected an
answer and astoundingly judge jackson
couldn't answer either one of them the
first one came from senator kennedy
when he asked her when do do the equal
protection laws attach to a human being
i mean that's a reasonable thing to ask
obviously he was inquiring about her
thoughts on abortion
and judge jackson said i gotta read you
the quote word for word
quote well um senator um i believe the
supreme court um actually i
well i actually don't know the answer to
that question i'm sorry i don't
in other words i don't know when a baby
is a human being or not she has no idea
now this was on top of the
the craziest answer i've ever heard
where the other day she was asked um
could she please supply a simple
definition on the difference between a
man and a woman what is a woman and she
said
i don't know i'm not a biologist now the
good news with her answer is there's now
a thousand memes out on the internet one
is funnier than the other but it's
rather terrifying
that a supreme court justice can't tell
you what's a woman and what's a man and
what's she going to do when cases come
her
regarding equal protection under the law
for men and women is it really going to
be like this if she's on the bench
i'll tell you exactly what she's going
to do once she's on once she is on the
supreme court she will rule in favor of
the most radical pro-abortion measures
and she will rule in favor of all kinds
of transgender
initiatives and anything that actually
undermines
the
obvious and natural difference between
men and women she knows very well the
answer to both questions but she's
beholden to her far left base which is
at war with reality on both issues
and so consequently she can't say
anything about it but we really know the
the whole world knows
where she's going to come down on these
issues and this is once again indication
of somebody that we really don't need on
the court somebody who is not
going to have the best interests of
americans at heart
it was shocking to watch the answer i
thought it was a joke until i watched
the tape and
a whole lot of people are very
distressed robert
for years the palestinian authority has
been criticized by the european union
for continuing to use textbooks
that are viciously anti-semitic very
violent and call for the death of the
jews now these are school children
reading these textbooks
and the european union said we're going
to stop funding you if you don't take
out the let's kill jews passages in your
school books and for
decades
the pa the palestinian authority has
been promised to do it well finally
after decades robert as you reported on
jihad watch
eu finally stepped them and said okay
we're gonna we're gonna call back 200
million euros that we're going to you
because you just won't renew
i'm sorry remove the kill all the jews
from your books
and of course the palestinian authority
flipped out
do you think
the money will buy the change the
europeans want
it well could
uh although it's certain that if it did
it would be a cosmetic change that would
be reversed once again as soon as the
eu's attention was elsewhere
because the
virulently
anti-semitic passages in the palestinian
textbooks are based straight on islamic
theology on the quran on the example of
muhammad
and on 1400 years of islamic
anti-semitism the idea that the jews
could be allowed a state is contrary to
the quran saying that the jews are the
worst enemies of the muslims chapter 5
verse 82 that they are under the curse
of allah chapter 9 verse 30.
so many other passages that are so
anti-semitic in the quran above all also
the imperative to drive them out from
where they drove you out which is
chapter 2 verse 191
the uh jews did not drive the arabs out
of israel but it is the palestinian-arab
historical myth that they did and
consequently they have this divine
command to drive out the jews they're
going to pursue this whatever the eu
does but there's no doubt that the eu
decision stunned the palestinian
leadership because they've been getting
away with this sort of thing for years
and nobody ever calls them to account
trump was the first and the eu was
against him and so now the eu is
behaving the way trump did
but probably they'll cave and probably
the palestinians realize that they'll
gave because they always have before
very
wise of you to notice and i would also
add as an addendum to what you just said
robert and biden has reversed all of
trump's policies on withholding money
because the palestinians were supporting
terror and as you said in our last show
biden is
expressly
violating the taylor force act giving
their money that he knows
is going to be used for terror shame on
biden and you know what well done eu i
hope you stick to your guns on this
robert where can people find out about
you and follow your work i'm at
ghodwatch.org barry and also jihadwatch
rs on twitter uh my books are available
for the most part at amazon and barnes
noble and any self-respecting bookstore
and as i say every time mr spencer joins
us read his stuff you need
to be educated and he's the scholar to
teach you about islam trust us at atp
so thanks for joining us today on atp
report we sure appreciate your attention
and hope you will subscribe it's always
free our content is always delivered
without cost for atp report i'm barry
nussbaum